buenos dias valentín a los líderes
europeos han abordado la crisis
alimentaria que se avecina a causa de la
invasión al de ucrania cada vez hay más
pruebas de que rusia está bloqueando las
exportaciones de trigo y también de
cereales de ucrania recordemos su planes
o de los principales exportadores
mundiales de cereales e incluso cada vez
hay más pruebas está mente que rusia
está incluso bombardeando también
almacenes que contienen el trigo y
también los cereales y no se consigue
controlar ni encontrar una solución los
líderes europeos han advierto han
advertido de una gran hambruna en varios
países 200 millones de personas en el
mundo dependen de este trigo por ello se
ha hablado de qué posibilidades puede
haber de hecho presente el consejo
europeo sales michelle va a viajar
próximamente a nueva york para hablar
con el secretario general de la onu
antonio guterres también han hablado con
el presidente de la unión africana macky
sall que han abordado la situación en el
continente africano porque es
especialmente urgente de hecho han
abordado la posibilidad de crear un
fondo de 500 millones de euros para
ayudar continente ante esta situación
porque no sólo se trata de una situación
humanitaria sino también tiene enormes
consecuencias también puede provocar una
grave crisis migratoria algo que también
ha alertado el presidente de ucrania
volodymyr telesquí en videoconferencia
con los líderes europeos ayer estar qué
significan para rusia y para los países
europeos las sanciones alcanzados en
esta cumbre
si de hecho tiene graves implicaciones
porque puede haber un aumento de los
precios en cualquier caso los países
europeos están preparados se habrá un
embargo del petróleo en dos pases
primero ese importe dejará de importar a
finales de año el petróleo de para que
llegue de mar y luego será producto aún
hay fechas concretas perdidas se está
preparando esta misma semana se espera
que se preparan estas sanciones en
cualquier caso es muy importante para
rusia 70.000 millones de euros que los
países europeos pagaron el año pasado
prácticamente se van a dejar a pagar a
partir de ahora para rusia